what is the best case you've ever heard
against extreme ownership and what's
your response or alternatively are there
situations where extreme ownership is
the wrong answer if you've never heard
an argument against let me propose to
okay one extreme ownership focuses too
much on achieving victory through focus
on strategy and tactics let me before
you even go there mmm I got asked that
question at the muster is there such a
thing as too much extreme ownership and
I said well yes there is actually such a
thing as too much extreme ownership for
instance and I actually broke it down to
the fact that there's two types of
extreme ownership that you're gonna have
internal and external internal is I own
everything and I know that but I'm not
sitting here telling everyone right
external is hey guys I'm gonna own this
this is me this is mine so you can
easily see from there where you can
overplay your hand of external extreme
ownership for instance echo you're in
charge of this project that we're doing
I want you to do it like this because I
own it
like that's obviously wrong right so if
I'm trying to get people to do things
like I'm trying to use decentralized
command and all I'm telling you everyone
was like this is my project
I own it echo you do this this is your
part of the project but the project is
mine right does that make does that
motivate you in any way no okay
so we're not gonna do that that would be
too much extreme ownership it would be
too much outward extreme ownership now
if so what I want to do is almost an
echo this is your project I'm gonna set
back let you run this thing I think
you've got a really good idea and vision
on how this is gonna work and I think
you could actually do a better job then
I can do so here's here's the goal that
we're trying to accomplish and if you
just you know come up with a plan and
tell me how you're gonna execute it I'm
standing by right now you're like whoa
chuckles trust me to do this that's
pretty cool right that's awesome so now
we have a good thing going so that's
that's what I'm gonna keep my ownership
internal
I'm not gonna project it on you keep it
internal now where this flips is the
project fails and clearly the example
now becomes crystal clear because now if
I use external ownership and I'm saying
I should use external ownership and when
the boss says hey joko your team failed
on this mission I'll say you know what
we did I've made some mistakes here
here's what I did wrong here's we made
the wrong investments I didn't allocate
resources well here my fault we're gonna
get it fixed next time around won't
happen mm-hmm okay that's cool that's
I'm now correctly using excessive
extreme ownership to take ownership of
the project that you actually screwed up
now obviously the wrong thing would be
hey Jocko this project failed and I say
oh that's cuz echo dropped the ball on
this he didn't get this done in time and
echos got issues over here now that's
not good I want to take I don't want to
use that I'm keeping my ownership
internal I'm being lame basically so yes
the the argument against extreme
ownership is yes if you take too much
ownership of a project and you're not
letting your you're not using enough
decentralized command that's why there's
a dichotomy between those two there's a
dichotomy between extreme ownership and
decentralized command and if I use too
much extreme ownership when I'm trying
to execute decentralized command it's
not gonna work right yeah now once a
mistake happens or there's failure
that's when you step in and take
ownership and by the way you should have
taken ownership all along to make sure
that the project didn't fail but these
things happen you don't win every single
time you don't care who you are now
he gave except a couple examples I'll
let you proceed with the question good
sir
okay he's gonna propose to example okay
extreme ownership focuses too much on
achieving victory through focus on
strategy and tactics but not assessing
whether war was worth fighting in the
first place for example maybe you
priority prioritize and execute and
cover and move and institute
decentralized command to become the
leading buggy whip manufacturer in the
country right beforehand you're Henry
Ford releases the Model T or maybe you
built the tightest sharpest most
aggressive sales team in history but the
product they're selling is praying
the weakness of poor or ignorant okay so
this is fairly simple now and in the
book extreme ownership I believe Chapter
three is called believe that is you
gotta believe in what you're doing and
part of believing in what you're doing
is understand why you were doing in what
you're doing and how it is beneficial in
the world mmm right so for instance that
both these examples would fail the test
of believing in what you're doing they
would fail the test anyone that was in
the transportation industry at the turn
of the century and would understand that
the buggy the horse buggy was doomed
when they started seeing reliable cars
come out on the streets and somebody
that truly exercises extreme ownership
would step up would adapt which is
another key concept of extreme ownership
and lead the transition from buggy whips
to this new technology of cars so it's
okay it's not you're gonna step up
you've got to make changes that's part
of ownership is looking and assessing
the other example where you're leading
extreme ownership you're leading
something that is preying on weak people
well then that doesn't pass the test
right that doesn't pass the test and
believing what you do because if I'm
like hey you know what I'm gonna get out
there do we go out there prey on extreme
people yeah you know that's one dude now
of course if you have a person that's a
sociopath or doesn't care about others
those are only out for themselves and
they exercise extreme ownership in order
to accomplish an evil mission well yeah
that's gonna be bad because people that
people that take ownership of things can
make things happen and if their cause is
evil then that's gonna be bad it's gonna
be a bad situation so you know the the
thing that's inherent in extreme
ownership is a true understanding of the
mission and belief in the mission and
the knowledge that you're doing the
right things for the right reasons which
is why these two examples are are
actually non issues mm-hmm and then he
gave another example what sample number
two yeah example number two is
the time and focus commitments required
to practice extreme ownership come at
too high a cost to your family we didn't
sign up for this for you no didn't sign
up for a mission and in the end the
gratification of having achieved your
objective won't be worth what you've
given up in your personal life perhaps
substantial ownership come on quotes is
a better fit for most people
okay well let's just not forget that
extreme ownership is not just about
business in any stretch it's about life
and you have to own the outcome in life
and that inherently includes balancing
between what you do for business and
what you do with your family now I'll
tell you that we hear all the time about
how extreme ownership actually saved
marriages not hurts them but saves them
and you know the husband will stop
blaming his wife or vice versa and look
at themselves and see where they can
improve instead of blaming your wife for
what's going wrong you say oh maybe it's
not cool that I do this particular thing
that I know annoys are right take some
ownership of that they take ownership of
the relationship and the problems in the
relationship and they fix them instead
of making excuses or pass on the blame
so extreme ownership is gonna help that
family then if you listen to the the
podcast with JP with JP Danelle on it
which is number 46 JP is taking
ownership of his marriage which was a it
actually were divorced at the time and
applied the simple laws of combat right
simplify cover and move and and got his
marriage back on track and so the
extreme ownership is not a hundred
percent focused on business it's focused
on life and the dichotomy is also there
that I talk about all the time that you
have to balance all the opposing forces
it's a chapter in the book called the
dichotomy of leadership right you've got
to balance these opposing forces in your
world now one of those opposing forces
is balancing the the pull of your family
with the pull of your work
and yeah you can go too far in one
direction you can go so far in one
direction that you lose your you can go
so work so hard and do such long hours
that you lose your debt then you lose
your family mm-hmm you can also do the
opposite where you're you don't do
enough for at work and you focus so much
in your family that you lose your job
which one of those is a good outcome
neither that's why you have to balance
neither one of those is a good outcome
yeah that's why you have to balance and
by the way it's one of those things -
I've seen this happen with your friends
of mine that have gone on sort of a
breakdown kind of downward spiral in
their life hmm I think this is
problematic people start having trouble
with their marriage right and they quit
their job mmm and they think oh now I'll
be able to spend more time but now all
of a sudden they don't have any money
and it turns into a disaster and I
always say look man think about this
your job is what how you provide for
your family so let's have a plan before
we move in this direction you got a
balance if you if you cuz if you throw
everything like I just said if you say
okay my jobs you know I'm too stressed
out and I'm just gonna leave my job and
just focus on my family now you've got
no income you got a whole new level
stresses coming at you cuz who's gonna
put the food on the table yeah so no
like one guys they stopped working out
after they get married because all I
gotta focus on my family my kids you
know no but Oh health down you know
health down yeah the energy down yeah
you know you become a low-energy father
we don't want that that's bad that's bad
for the whole family so yeah that's
another thing if you got if you got your
your wife or your husband is saying hey
you know you're working out all the time
or you know I don't like this say hey
here's the benefits you know do you want
me to be around for an extended period
of time you want me alive past 60 do you
want me to be healthy do you want me to
be able to defend our family should
there be some kind of an encounter you
know I know I do want to be able to
defend this family yeah so yeah I got to
spend a little extra time on their gun
range yeah I got to spend a little extra
time on the jiu-jitsu math yes I'm gonna
work out
that's I'm doing that you think I'm
doing it for me I'm doing it for us for
us you know I'm doing it for us no of
course the balance that do because you
can go
overboard there too yes we're you know
careful like working out is not to be
confused with going to the gym there's
some bulls a huge separation there yeah
so guys will like go to the jammers
let's face it there is a big element of
social there you know that social
component and jujitsu we've got amazing
stuff what do you mean when you go to
jujitsu like you there's a lot of
hanging out you mean talking about like
yeah you're friends of course so some
people they'll be like hey I'll go to
jujitsu meanwhile new baby whatever hey
I'm gonna do Jitsu but then they'll roll
for the hour hour and a half and then
three and a half four hours later
they'll come home yeah I also just I was
doing jujitsu here's the benefit like
yeah you did the jujitsu for hour and a
half the other for what however long you
were cruisin with your friends in the
lounge
drinking acai yeah don't do don't
confuse it is or gotta have balance or
use it you know how people use it like
that it go but you know yeah that's good
and you know these questions what I
liked about them is you saying hey you
know basically put the extreme ownership
attitude into the UFC cage and let's see
how it does in these problem examples
hmm so I think I think it does alright
or just get your home gym you know yeah
I definitely recommend the home gym